hello everyone and welcome back to some
more daily rapid action I'm gonna
continue uh playing a rapid game says it
uh helps improve a little bit and you
guys seem to enjoy them uh and I I'm
pretty sure I have to play seven more to
get raided uh or uh maybe I've played
Seven and then I need like 20 I I don't
know how many you need like I don't know
if it's 10 or 20. uh so let's continue
10 minutes per player uh let's uh dive
straight into it I um I played a few
bullet games to prepare for this session
and I even defeated the Grand Master so
I was very happy about that but then I
checked who the Grand Master was and uh
I'm not gonna name the the Grand Master
but I
um I was very impressed when I saw that
he is 74 years old so 74 and uh playing
bullet and he uh I checked out his
profile he pretty much exclusively plays
bullets so I mean what uh what a true
warrior I mean what a what a way to live
so um but yeah still was very nice
uh so okay uh we are currently up to
2201 in rating and uh as I'm only
playing against higher rated opponents
uh could be uh yeah okay
uh our our next opponent is uh lick
double zero uh with a rating of two two
two nine so let's uh let's go for E4 and
if you haven't seen my previous video
from the final round of the uh girls uh
World Championship do check it out it's
uh quite a quite a brutal game all right
so we're uh a nice E4 E5 we're gonna go
We're not gonna go for rui Lopez I'm
more of a
Joko piano kind of person uh and it will
yeah I already thought we were maybe
gonna have an event Gambit but he goes
for the early H6 and I know it's not a
good move like uh
I've never seen it actually played now
what's H6 how do we how do we play
against H6
huh
let's go for B4
doesn't matter that he didn't go for the
standard Evans now I'm actually allowing
him to develop the bishop with Tempo uh
but he lost a Tempo with H6 so I can
maybe kind of transpose into the Evans
Gambit with uh uh me giving him a Tempo
and then he wastes the tempo on H6 so I
don't know if it's possible but uh you
know we will find out
all right so he goes for the for the
standard stuff here
um so this is kind of
yeah let's let's give up the C3 Pawn as
well if if he's interested
if not then uh it's gonna be a very
strong Center so I'm very happy about
that so I'm pretty sure he he will
capture sometimes people play D3 because
it's very annoying uh and I actually
prefer when people take or just play
anything
uh then go for this but yeah all right
so I guess we take grab the full Center
so this isn't bad we're only down a pawn
and I'm still calling this uh waste of a
Tempo regardless okay he does control G5
now but
I don't know I I don't like it for black
oh
like next I can play E5 maybe and if he
castles I can even throw in D5 so
not not really liking this for him so
let's uh
I don't know what to call this so we'll
check after we'll check afterwards if
this has a name
yeah okay uh
D4 he's really giving this a lot of
thought
also probably knows uh how to play the
Evans Gambit with black but not sure how
to tackle the H6 line as I mean who
would probably no one played B4 in that
position Okay so
what do we go for here now do we want to
play something
weird
or no
like something like D5 Knight A5 D6 is
that even possible
nah no it's not
I'm just I'm only joking but maybe maybe
if we play captures on F7 then play D5
then he moves the Knight and then we
harass the king a little bit throw in
the queen
uh maybe somewhere
um
I don't know it's pretty pretty
committal and I don't I haven't really
developed my pieces all that much just
yet
ah
yeah okay let's just continue developing
if he castles that then D5 I'm sure is
very annoying
we'll see I have a feeling both of us
will waste a lot of time on this
like if it was a bullet game or or even
Blitz that'd probably just go for Bishop
captures on F7 but since it's rapid and
he has also a lot of time to calculate
uh probably it's uh it's a bad idea
but we're gonna check probably probably
it's bad but who knows
so while castling is nice I'm sure uh I
I kind of feel like D5 or D6 has to be
played here
he doesn't play it
it's uh very interesting
okay now we'll go for E5 I don't want to
play D5
default right away because then he can
play D6 if I play E5 and he plays D6 I
can then play I can then play D5 huh
so many interesting Pawn pushes
or do we just open up the dark Square
Bishop
uh since he still can't go 95 that's
pretty bad and then we just shift the
bishop over to D3
and somehow somehow get the Knight into
the game
or E5 first what do you think I'm sure
you guys think something you just can't
tell me as I haven't uploaded this yet
oh
or do we just develop
yeah if there's nothing concrete it's
always better to just develop
uh do I do I mind these six then yeah
I'm pretty sure I should somehow stop it
yeah these are his next two moves D6 and
Bishop to G4 if I do nothing about that
so let's play E5
would be very interesting
yeah okay so he goes D5 and now uh I
could shift my Bishop to D3 but
I'm not going to I'm going to capture up
a song
and now
okay so of course he brings the queen
into the game
uh let's get our let's get our Knight
into the game so he now has pressure on
D4 we are defending it sufficiently and
of course if he goes here we go Knight
B5 so he's probably gonna play A6 next
no he goes for the bishop all right
makes sense Let's uh let's harass the
queen
we harass the queen
then is D5 an option
yeah my Pawn is definitely better on D5
than on okay so I cannot play D5 now as
he would challenge my dashup and he
wants to trade now of course as as he
should
on the other hand
I
probably don't even mind him playing
this so we're just gonna
try and trick him into capturing my
knight
yeah let's try and trick him
I want him to capture this
then whatever happens to the d-pawn we
will have the nice Bishop there and we
might get the semi-open G file for our
Rook
okay so he does capture okay let's do it
he will probably kick away my knight
which is great because he of course
wants to win the pawn here
but uh D5 is a problem
yeah so he has to figure out how to deal
with D5
it's not not a huge problem because he
always has Queen to G6 check all right
so he introduces another attacker
very nice
okay so I play here check King H1 he has
to move the Knight probably Knight E5
and then uh he attacks my Bishop
well that's that's very nice very nice
yeah next he's gonna play A6
but first let's play King H1
King H1 first
now we we don't really care if he takes
here then he is uh sort of in a in a bad
spot
so probably okay so he does take very
interesting
very interesting that he doesn't care
about the C7 on
hmm
okay so I will definitely take yeah I
mean
Knight captures of course of course the
Knight captures and he doesn't have any
checks so I'm actually very happy here
let's go King G1 no
can we play it yeah we can actually
offer this Pawn because then we will be
able to capture on G7 so for the moment
let's offer this spawn
quite a quite a wild position
okay so Knight C6
I like it
I like it uh
yeah let's just uh let's just move the
queen yeah but we can't really move the
queen to a decent Square
okay this is this looks a bit dangerous
but let's go for it
yeah I'm banking everything here on the
bishop pair
be definitely
got a very nice position out of this but
my double drugs and the g file and the
bishop pair eyeing his King here
should be
should be a pretty big problem
now he can't yeah okay he can play that
G6 is never an option that's uh for sure
okay so
very nice uh
um
yeah very nice
have to give up the light Square Bishop
even if I don't want to but it's um yeah
it's
just nothing better here
yeah I did consider capturing here first
which is probably best as it will allow
me to grab a little bit of material back
unless I'm really blundering something
um
he's up three points which means I have
to I have to really cash in nicely here
and he does allow this okay so that's uh
that's nice let's capture uh maybe
capturing with the bishop but no I think
this is better
now we go here
do we go here
yeah we go here I feel like there are
too many threads here like the C7 Pawn
is hanging which he should ignore uh oh
nice he's going for he's going for this
yeah
kind of missed that poorly poorly poorly
oh that's sad
very sad but is it a dangerous check
that's the question
is that a dangerous trick
no I don't think it is I don't think it
is we could actually allow this
huh
wow
did I even
[Music]
very very good stuff
all right let's do it Bishop F6
[Music]
we're attacking The Rook we're
threatening mate and if Knight captures
yeah we're gonna attack the Knight and
what is his next move he has to play
Rook to D2
oh he has that
okay
so missed that a little bit but we're
are we okay
[Music]
we'll take here
we'll go here
yeah he defended well
ah
he defended well
yeah he's completely winning now but we
are going to we are going to try and
make it
uh a bit difficult for him
yeah four minutes on the clock I don't
see I don't see it happening yeah
yeah he this is gonna capture this Pawn
Yeah now he goes King E6
I should resign this but I'm gonna I'm
gonna make him fight for it which is
which is very difficult from this
position but uh you should never just
yield a full point
so King E6 and really nothing to worry
about here
uh I will then of course try to
somehow box his King off or rather cut
off his King and then try and push the H
Pawn but
okay so he goes for this instead that's
very interesting
okay rock on the seventh rank is uh
always interesting
let's push
it will push I will capture here
now he plays that instead all right so
let's stop it
now he pushes we're gonna deliver a
check and take on C6 okay so he's gonna
get uh his pawns doubled
or he's gonna push the B Pawn also
possible
huh
yeah of course he'll do that
all right so uh that was the blunder but
of course a blunder in a losing position
so it doesn't matter
okay so it's just uh let's just see what
was
what was the truth of the position
okay so uh B4 obviously gets to check
the question mark but it's uh you know
zero zero position so this was perfectly
fine C capture snygos yeah and D5
obviously uh the preferred move but
nothing spectacular both are like zero
zero point three
uh E5 oh it's okay D5 preferred there
you go
a lesson in Pawn pushing
the five captures captures I bring the
queen in Bishop G4 Knight here okay so
objectively he's already winning here
there we go yeah okay see he's up up by
three
[Music]
he goes for the queen capture trading is
fine yeah okay so and now okay this was
a mistake yeah capture him capturing was
a mistake Bishop captures and Rook
captures should be a draw Rook to G1 oh
no Rook to H7 first
yeah Rook to H7 forcing King to E7 and
that's the good stuff here yeah Rook to
G1 is just too optimistic but I I put
everything on this checkmating idea of
Bishop to F6 and I missed his night job
night capture skin here yeah Knight D5
ah you know they say when there's a
knight there's a way and here there was
uh definitely a very strong night yeah
yeah captures n95 oh that's uh
so unfortunate but what are you gonna do
yeah I thought about the characters on
C7 but it doesn't matter the position is
already lost here
yeah
yeah good stuff so not not terrible uh
to two moves that really could have been
played better but in the end he was uh
he was always better pretty much for the
entire game and uh well just
uh took it took it all the way but very
interesting cure yeah on the uh Ponte H6
and then Pawn to B4 uh does it have a
name nope does not have a name but there
you have it uh you you you've seen what
happens if you play it uh so yeah uh
that's the game hope you enjoyed it uh I
will see you soon and do check out the
video that I mentioned in the beginning
my previous one it's it's a very nice
one